ngày đầu tiên ăn dặm của anh so
nấu cháo với sữa mẹ nha
đầu tiên mình sẽ chuẩn bị một cái nồi nấu chậm như thế này
mình sẽ nấu cháo với tỉ lệ là 10
một gạo và 10 nước nha
đầu tiên mình sẽ lấy một cái thìa gạo như thế này đây nha
đó rồi lấy 8 thìa nước nha các bà 8 thìa nước
sau đó thì mình sẽ chuẩn bị 2 cái thìa sữa mẹ
để một lát sau khi mà mình nấu xong rồi mình sẽ mix với sữa mẹ nha
8 thìa nước nha một 2 BA 4 năm 6 7 8
sau khi mà đã nấu được cháo như
thế này rồi mình sẽ Cho vào rây
rồi mình rây nha mấy bà cái rây như này đó
à các bà Cho vào xay
cũng được các bà không nấu cháo mà các bà nấu bột cũng không SAO luôn nha
mà cảm giác là cháo ray nó kiểu nó sánh hơn ấy
chìa xong rồi miết nó xuống như này thôi các bà đây này
đó sẽ bắt đầu nó sẽ có cái độ sánh như này này đó
ờ với buổi đầu tiên mình sẽ dây làm 2 lần nha bà
còn đây là sữa mẹ mà tôi đã chuẩn bị Ra đây các bà
để lúc nào mà cháo nó gần chín rồi cháo nó chín rồi
ấy thì các bà hãm vắt nha
để Cho nó đỡ bị để Ra ngoài môi trường nó lâu quá đó là
tỉ lệ là một gạo 10 nước đúng không mình chỉ đong 8
thìa nước thôi còn đây là 2 cái thìa sữa mà mình sẽ Cho vào
mình sẽ Cho vào đây mình dây luôn
đấy 2 thìa sữa nha bà
sẽ rây mình sẽ rây luôn cả vào nồi đây là lần rây thứ 2
lăn tăn lăn tăn một chút là mình có thể bỏ Ra được rồi nha
ㅎㅎ
음
안녕하세요
不要开不要开
똑바로 해라 고마워
Ja
hết rồi nè